what is up fighter and the kids what's
up turkeys a
few little housekeeping notes for you
about the road
uh west palm beach me and this crew is
in florida we're gonna get our buns out
sun's out
bun's out i will be there with my new
man bun west palm beach
december 31st through january 2nd and
then just announce
san marcos texas right outside austin
right outside san antonio
new spot there the mark all right we're
doing two shows only
limited seating there will be special
guests there with me as well in texas
limited seating two shows only on friday
two shows only on saturday
that is january 29th and january 30th
san marcos texas tickets go on sale
thursday
december 10th at 8 00 a.m pacific
you can get your tickets and go fast so
get em texas san marcos texas
january 29th through january 30th it
just got added to the site tfatk.com
get your tickets texas this episode of
t-fat kz
is brought to you by the one on only we
talking about on it on it.com
for all your supplement needs we got
freaking creatine glutamine electrolytes
earth grown nutrients my favorite krill
oil joint oil
total hemp we got protein powder all
sorts of protein powders
we got freaking alpha brain i don't do
anything without my alpha brain i like
to put in my water
we got fitness gear kettlebells battle
ropes
we got freaking uh all sorts of stuff
man steel club maces
we got streaming fitness at on at 6
barbell body weight
streaming fitness for your thick ass we
got apparel tease
workout gear for your girl for you for
your side piece for your man for your
uncle
for your hairy ass mom we got it all
women stops men's tops
shorts pants leggings all right we got
it all go to onit.com
fighter for ten percent off the entire
freaking site they got coffee it's [ __ ]
yeah
coffee black rifle and on it collabs my
favorite coffee on the planet
on it you need to send me some more i'm
all out go to onit.com the coffee and
anything i just mentioned on it.com
slash fighter 10 off
ooh yep not doing it yeah you ready i
don't even want to
pop it up i don't even want any of that
to go let me show you how long you're
pretending i can take slices home
i'm not taking a slices home guaranteed
first of all i'm cutting you off
why i don't know why uh i don't we both
have three slices no i'm telling you
what i'm cutting you off from what did
you do
food i'm cutting you off yeah out of my
life when it comes to food you don't
wait why
because we like the same [ __ ] no no no
no no no
you getting the biscuits and gravy dogs
i heard it and i'm like
well [ __ ] if brenda getting the biscuits
what you doing exactly
i know you enable me so i gotta i gotta
split the road dawg
oh [ __ ] but we like the same [ __ ] like
you're doing beyonce
you're kelly rowland oh [ __ ] you were
danny's child that's where i'm at right
now dude
that's where i'm at well let them know i
ain't doing no more talking no more
because every time i seem to talk about
it you mute i get i'm mute i'm just
working you working
i'm just worried you gotta say to that
hey man we'd like to say that
good luck this [ __ ] good luck good
luck good luck when we're on the road
he's nice
wait wait wait till we get to uh well
i'm at palm beach i don't know how the
food is there
wait till we get to the
san marcos san marcos texas 20 minutes
away from austin
oh you did the road that's my city
austin you see that's my crib
that's his crib i know all the good food
spots everything
your you and me are gonna chow down and
then
i'll i'll fight i'll find one of those
delivery services or door dad you ain't
doing that
i'll find one of those delivery services
where they'll bring the wheels for you
oh really
while the rest of us are [ __ ] lit at
the restaurants you're just going to
order your food and eat at the house
kill it and then i'm gonna take my shirt
off when i get these [ __ ] abs
i know it would be nice is it worth it
though are you taking a shirt does it
work
hold on worth it to give up this
delicious food yeah [ __ ] because
she was making fun of my snoring
oh what you did
like people call you fat like damn i
didn't get my [ __ ] together yeah
i get it all the time there was a
picture of thomas they took for
christmas
oh yeah tell me before we get into this
you want to tell people why you got the
man bun
oh yeah very good point about that i
don't know
pretend like didn't happen fly as [ __ ]
really
just i mean am i premier league soccer
player i don't know
tell me yeah all right i thought you was
joking am i going to go on love island
at uk
i don't know okay i don't know are you
serious but here's the
thing no you know i was rocking that
mullet but that was just a that was just
the transition to get to the man bikes
like i need my hair to get longer i
heard that too
am i here to get longer and then a few
nights ago i the
mun band was the was the plan for quite
some time we just needed to take time to
grow out
but then the other night i was chilling
with my girl yeah and i uh was like oh
can you uh put my
hair up because it's always in my face
i'm wearing a hat she's like you know
you wear a hat every [ __ ] show like
you're always wearing hats you got good
hair
like you know i just don't feel like
doing i don't know what to do and i get
this [ __ ] weird mullet
she's like yeah that's cool can i be
honest with you i'm like yeah what's up
she goes i [ __ ] hate your hair
that's lovely but really she's like i
can't stand the moment
we're gonna be doing this all the time
yeah i saw the email you saw the emotion
i can't do that now dude
all the [ __ ] take this out you pull it
down
yeah watch tv and then he'll have his
hair like regular then a commercial
break is right here in the front
he's like this what the hell bro i'm
like hey guys
dude me and my girl are super into that
season five of
uh can i tell you i watched it now now
season five
season five girl season five's the
better one uh it's good
yeah i i didn't finish season six but
it's good i didn't finish these things
we won't say that for the road season
five
six for the rounds season five me and my
girl we watched it she was like oh my
god this is so boring she don't
understand
right you gotta let it marinate the
learn the character now now i gotta ask
you a question about this right
the black girl i see what you're saying
the 28 year old guy he's
he was the weakest one i'm beyonce with
the black girl
the black girl he was like yo i'm at
this part where they're having a
conversation
and he was like yo i want to keep my
options open she was like yeah i
understand i understand yeah
it's done i understand the black guy no
the black the black girl with the older
uh white guy the twin oh yeah yes oh
yeah yeah you're talking
about the young young like light skinned
black girl yes yes yeah the baddie but i
love the surfer chick everyone loves
lucy dude i love losers
she is gorgeous that's the blondie yeah
i love him loves her she has so many
dudes out there right now don't sleep on
the black guy with his
chick anna oh you talking about that kim
kardashian
kim kardashian uk yes yes shorty is bad
i'm like yo why i think her ass is fake
though
so what i don't care oh okay no he's
just saying anything i'm just giving my
thoughts on it oh she's bad though she's
bad and she gets better as the season
goes on i was thinking
she's eating like she's in the house is
this one 50 episodes too
i think so because they you know they
filmed so i lived it up
so you know because i'm like damn well
they get lit like the real world or the
ultimate fighter
so they have rules they have strict
rules in uk oh
you can only have two drinks per day a
week so like
in my two drinks i'll just fill both up
to the top of whisk and be lit as [ __ ]
up yeah that's all it takes
so they can only have two drinks they
can't get hammered um
if they have sex on the show that next
morning they go
they go to therapy and talk about it
they have to use protection
they're in the house monday through
sunday they get saturdays off
they can't have their phone and they
can't talk to anybody in the outside
world
when you see them with their phone
there's no service they can just take
pictures to document it later
after they get off what about when they
make texts they make 200
i think that's the the they're oh they
can text each other in the house yeah
but they can't text the outside world
okay so their phones are set up with the
can only text producers yeah and
each other but they can't tell anybody
what's going on because the producer
sends the text like oh you gotta
you gotta but the producer also give
them ideas what to talk about
oh would you like hey what do you think
of this and then they talk about or why
don't you go talk to that like you know
yeah you should
talk to the director yeah lucy his
reality show lucy should have went with
tyson fury brother though i didn't like
how she stayed with old boy though i
ain't like that
have you been are you at the part where
molly may comes
the girl not the blind i'm not there
that's like what episode four or five
uh i think so yeah just wait for it
once you know the characters oh man yeah
you're invested and the new people
coming out who the [ __ ] this
neighborhood i know
it's great it's getting ambassador so
you know it's on for
[ __ ] 50 weeks straight but they don't
shoot on like
saturdays so this p they get saturdays
to go out and like
explore the world and come back oh damn
and then
you they you pay for this [ __ ] each
contestant gets i think it's 250 pounds
a week
which it was about i think that's around
four hundred dollars a week
oh i thought i thought you were talking
about somebody wait uh
so yeah yeah yeah but they get so famous
that's what i'm saying like yeah that's
what i was gonna say they they get so
famous off of it that's like
yeah i'll make this four hundred dollars
a week right now but but like but like
ultimate fighter you get like how much i
think you get maybe
a thousand dollars a week like you don't
get much money well you were saying the
same thing if you win the fight you get
like
if you win by knockout you get five
grand oh if you lose you get like a
grand like you're not balling
but that's what you said the same thing
with merit at first sight they don't
even get paid them no
because the mayor at first sight wants
you to actually look for levels
what if you love money i get it you know
i'm obsessed with uh
love island yeah can i start saying
factor 50. you know what that means
what's that yeah watch enough love
island
factor 50 means like hype level factor
thing like they'll be like yo you need
to
factor 20. you take your factor 10. that
means lower
you factor 50. i mean jude williams is
that a uk thing i think so i've never
heard of it but i'm starting to use them
oh let's use it exactly dog you just use
it if that's a bit
are we allowed to use it in fact you're
50. factor 50.
what's the highest they go to 50 50.
was like gonna go talk to girl he's like
yo don't be factor 50.
he's like where should i be i think he's
like be like factor 10 factor 20.
how's that dig that it's the phrase in
reference to the sun cream and used to
describe someone who's
trying too hard factor 50 was heavily
used in season four which i'm watching
uh how consensus should not behave so
factor 50.
okay oh fractional 50. you're doing too
much
you're doing too much doing too much
chill out like show me
i'll tell you what and uh tyson fury's
little brother
tommy fury i like him real good with the
ladies really good with his words
really how old i like him he cool he's
like 20 20 yeah
yeah so tyson's older tyson's
30-something but the guy he's such a
like a cool guy he's a good guy yeah
he's a cool guy
yeah you're just 32 years old oh we're a
year apart the best heavyweight in the
world right now
hands down yeah yeah no you wouldn't you
didn't you was talking about that [ __ ]
before he fought wilder and then you saw
him fight wilder and walter get his ass
beat
and now you own tyson fury what is that
bandwagon no it's not bad like it's
called being realistic
respect i mean respect like the guy beat
deontay wilder twice
in my opinion and i was like all right
i'll give him credit credit
listen deante wilder i love him so much
because he started boxing late at 29
years old he was bagging groceries
there's only so much at 24. well 24 24
i'm sorry 20 which is
alex yeah and he went to the olympics
and the only one who got brothers
got a bronze so the fact that i love his
story and then he's
heavyweight champion of the world and
then you have tyson you know why he
started fighting because his he
was mad at someone no no not at all he
had a daughter he had a daughter who was
really sick and she needed like uh
like medical uh care so she had real bad
problem
he's like i need to start making money
because he want to play i think football
for alabama
then he's like it's gonna take too long
to make money he's like got it money
so i'm gonna start fighting and then
[ __ ] he did he goes straight to
boxing or was he like straight
underground nope
he's younger yeah uh he's probably 30
something too he might be 29. his story
is like a real live giant cube movie
he's a great oh is is his daughter good
85
yeah he loves this yeah she's good he
they have uh i think
three kids now with his baby he's got
three kids maybe mom
she's they're great yeah he's such a
good person man he's great yeah i saw
you you into the best interviews yeah
he's such a good person
i apologize for going so aggressive on
you i thought she was bandwagoning
i thought she was like pulling the
golden state warriors thing where
everybody was riding with oh how about
your boy harden
oh he's like i need to trade philly but
no he wanted uh to brooklyn
and i don't it's not working out so i
think that's a bad idea for him to go to
brooklyn
why there's not enough basketballs for
him and kyrie together a lot of people
said that but
you understand the steve nash system
kyrie irving oh yeah
what's steve nash system he's never
coached
he was with he he's kd guy and golden
and i'm just saying he never you know
he's never
steve now this is his first headquarters
head coach and you know what i'm saying
so when people say that it's like
is that what's the total thing okay
because that was
can i be honest steve kerr won a
championship when he first uh his first
season of coach well i'm not saying he's
not gonna be a good coach steve steven
that's
my favorite coach okay i'm sure we say
it's his scene steve kerr
steve nash my favorite coach he's this
is first year i know he's my favorite
i was trying to grow up steve
is
what steve nash did let's talk about
steve nash he's a
6-4 guard for the suns
he came he's canadian once i think
university uh
santa clara or some [ __ ] like that two
times what two or three time mvp
well two absolutely he didn't he didn't
deserve the other one
rob kobe done hey rob let me let me look
at his awards yep one both
as a white point guard into in the
current nba to win
[ __ ] two mvps is insane i'll give you
that as a little canadian
like he's not big yeah yeah like
columbia
mvp of the nba his friends are like
probably not buddy what
and [ __ ] he's up it was a great
system he was so good it was dan tony's
system
it was yeah yeah it was but but i
remember because uh the spurs knocked
this uh
knocked us out of the playoffs
nobody freaking uh broke uh nash's nose
yeah this is vague
right yes no does that have to do i'm
trying to
i'm trying to keep watching i know i
feel you yeah
long story short i think you think hard
goes to sixers yeah like do you know the
gm from houston's with the six
yes uh mur uh what's in dude you got he
in trouble
forgot his name but uh he'd be good on
sixers yeah i like
with him and him beat if you trade for
simmons
the african dude now this is what i'm
thinking and philly should do uh yeah
we'll give you simmons but you give us
harden uh and some draft picks because
let me just tell you why it's not an
even trade
i'm saying i'm i'm sorry houston should
say we will give you harden but you give
a simmons and like a couple of your
draft picks
because let's be honest simmons and
harden you choose harden all day
and the gap is what it depends on the
team what the hard
hardened to me like the his style of
playing just you know he needs the ball
all the time like what's he ever wanted
that's that wait
you love you love steve nash and then
tony he uh steve nash has the ball all
the time
yeah so it's his system so you take your
passer hard
hard and drop dimes yeah you're right
but he's i don't know i'm just not i'm
not so
and i like harding i'm okay i like
carter okay what i'm saying listen
up hear me out hear me out that's right
him and embiid and doc river system
that's solid that's uh yeah yeah he has
shooters around him yeah so
so even with that trade you still would
take simmons over
harden i think so like if simmons goes
to golden state oh that's better than
that
that's not that's something like i think
if you let simmons be like that guy like
you surround him with greatness he would
do good in golden state dude he would
thrive at golden state yeah
yeah but yeah i think so yeah i agree i
agree yeah yeah
well i want to go back to love island
real quick and we'll oh yeah i know
and then i'm gonna get back to this fat
[ __ ] oh yeah let's get back
okay let me get back to the love island
i love how they set you up right so it's
four women not five women lined up and
the guys come down
now this is when they let you know if
you ugly or not right so five women
yeah they step out of here yo
have you seen the show yeah steven said
you didn't like it
he is a [ __ ] liar i love love island
i
also started like where you guys live
yeah so i
didn't start from episode one i don't
think you really need it so i don't know
why your girlfriends need to start
from episodes if you've never seen it
though like yeah you know but like one
episode you're kind of caught up you
kind of get the feel for personalities
you kind of
like yeah that is true it's kind of like
you don't need to go back like
keep up yeah but it's long conversations
it's kind of boring that's what my girl
was saying
you want to get invested in the
characters no yeah but she couldn't
understand i had my faves
like she couldn't understand how they
talk like she was like that oh put
subtitles on
oh she said that i was like nah i was
just translating for
my bad no it's amazing i love love
island
i think i'm going to get hulu so i can
watch all of the seasons i try to buy it
on amazon
six on there yeah i try to do it through
amazon they only have seasons one and
two from the uk
a lot of them can do it through a lot of
fans hit me up saying we need to watch
season three
i heard season four is good i heard
season five was the one they said season
three
but season five is what we were watching
and uh no we're watching something i'm
watching
five's lit yeah that's what i heard i
heard that you got that dope surfer girl
i love you guys oh she's so funny tyson
for your brother tyson fury's
brother but then there's this dancer on
there yeah he's so chill
he came in with uh tyson fury i want to
hang out he's pretty good i want to hang
out with him
he went for the ugg again we love all
women
but she's really proper british she's
like real like
british universe what do you mean like
like bosh
stereotypically english like if you have
that style like that proper english
style like what's she like
j probably think she's hot jay likes
proper english like my queen
what does she look like remember my
family's from england so it's like
the like the accent stuff maybe that's
why that's why you look like that
like what the man yeah like premier
league soccer player but extra thick
yeah yeah doug
but i think i like the accents because
my grandma talks like in my hands talk
like that so i love it i don't know it
brings back to home
so you you cool with the girl that he's
like chopping it up
nope but i understand why he did it
because because i'm like it's proper
english and the other thing is it's like
uh but look notice how the guys are
different like let's say
well not chin but let's say it's like
you me
uh chappelle jay and stevie
and it's not that we're disrespectful we
just talk different about
women than the english do like they're
very vernacular
like do you remember chompers the guy
who definitely don't but
chompers but yeah like he calls you
girls birds like oh wait compared to
them yeah you're
you're so if i'm over here they're over
here you're like in the middle
in the middle yeah because they're like
no it's like they don't
they really they just say oh man she's
fit mate she's fit man but that
you know like yeah and over here
they're just more i don't think they're
like more outwardly with it because
they'll talk about that
one of the twins like how she has a
great bum like it just sounds more
polite when they say yes
like they're not aggressive about it
yeah it's not wrong
they say yo or they call the girls first
he's the guy who shaves his leg and his
mom says his bum he's bodybuilding
he's bodied up but he's short i was like
yo
you rooting for him because that's how i
was but she left him
she's leaving him yeah and she was like
she was so eager because she never been
and here's the thing about these guys
over there
in the uk she he was like yo she never
had a boyfriend
that really worried dude i was like bro
that's great
she don't have a commitment huh well you
talking about uh the
other girl yeah no no no no the girl he
was paired up a little alarming
did you have certain agents did you ever
have a boyfriend yeah she was old too
i'm in my first relationship ever your
story's a little different
your origin story's a little different
no no because people try to hate on
these people that have never been in
relationships before you know why though
but you were working on yourself you're
going through some demons you didn't
have time for a girl
now look at you crushing life yeah got a
girl
got a dope crib does it find yourself a
dog
does this girl have demons no well
she does it you said it
it took as long as enough hang
how old is how this girl she's girl
she's older i think 27 which is old for
that
okay bro she probably has she's probably
good she got some choppers on it it just
depends i don't but
you think it is a commitment thing hold
on like it's a commitment issue if
you've never
i guess if you've never been in a
relationship does it depend on now
how you are as a person is what you're
saying i don't think that's true but
like if you can't commit to someone
that's not it that's not that season
looks [ __ ] dope
it's season four doug not season five
right five or four
season five this is a five but they
don't have really good pictures
oh there they are yeah
okay back there now the other pink to
your left far left
oh this one yeah that's her that's her
look at that she doesn't look bad
bro no she's not bad but compared to the
other girls
like before you learn about the kid the
the people on the show like
you just go based off look she can't
close the [ __ ] you can't close her mouth
she's smiling
dude can we talk about the surfer let's
see
she's like jewel uh she does kind of
look like jewels she's like jewel
and she's and i was saying i was saying
she's doing an angel
so jewel and angel had a baby and she
serves look at her
oh wow like i hate impenetrating real
now oh like a hail
yeah like a hayden peneterry yeah yeah
but yeah nevermind shout out to
what yeah but what nothing you gonna let
it slide
nope you're gonna you go yep that's cool
all right all right
cause i was curious but yes listen those
pictures don't do that girl body justice
i'm talking about she is come on bro did
she find a man
she found she found a man i'm an episode
spoiler i'm on i'm on episode three so
how are you
literally spoil anything for me and i'll
still watch you know what the natural
progression for people on love island is
they go over to the challenge that's
like their next tv
yeah oh do they do that yeah a lot of
people are from love island
no they end up going to the challenge
road rules because after love island
like they have
this huge following but they don't know
what to do with it they come over to the
states
yeah and they start doing shows here
really and then with the challenge they
don't do road rules anymore like what
theo used to do where you spend like a
year in a city
yeah like they don't do that anymore and
so they get from other reality tv shows
to be on that show
so you mean and a lot of people are on
uh level they just they just
circle from like all reality show to
reality to reality show yeah
uh the challenge so you have a reality
like show career
yes there's kind of like a natural
progression in it it's like if you win
big brother you go to
challenge or amazing race if you do love
island you go to the challenge or you'll
do like x on the beach or something
i heard excellent so wait if you so say
you win big brother you can't just like
chill and sit on that money you can but
those are thirsty
how much most of you taste what's the
win
what happens when you win love and hip
hop where do you go uh
loving hip hop i think the best thing
you can do is
become cardi b but i don't i
the biggest female musician like she's
so [ __ ] big
but there was something about her like
there's been you know however many
seasons she was a star
dude as soon as she was on the screen
like oh my god like even without her
using just personality and her
like charisma on camera she was a star
damn she got her teeth fixed and
everything
but her but it's down there she's funny
her teeth she's like man i'm wearing i
won't suck dick is good if they fix my
teeth
she's not trying to be funny or anything
she's like legit concerned
mm-hmm she's like man she was like my
man's gonna be pissed if i figured look
at her
offset shout out look at her
wow so that was her own love and hip hop
yeah so who who did
what rapper was she with no one no uh no
one her storyline was that she was a
stripper she was making
a producer she was dating him for a
little bit he said that he would help
her career
out of atlanta uh out of new york new
york and what ended up happening was i
guess they
had a falling out she got so big off the
show she came out with bodak yellow and
just blew the [ __ ] up
wow
when i heard that i was like okay
because you know she stole that beat
from uh kodak black
yeah ain't no flying white it's called
that's right it's called yellow or black
or whatever the [ __ ]
bodak yellow yeah yeah yeah yeah come on
you should have known that one yeah
reality shows are interesting
it is interesting because no one really
like is is it so it's rare that someone
really becomes a star off of it i mean
you can garner a very large following
now especially within the pandemic
yeah because social media social media
is huge and then there's a bunch of
people watching you right now while
they're working at home
the only thing is what do you do from
there because you would like the
bachelor the bachelorette
like they kind of get big but then it's
like some people on the bachelorette go
into the challenge
too bro you remember it just doesn't
last that long for them i guess
but would they because
there's a mom on teen mom who she
created
a uh they're all trying to get him
podcasting but she created her like own
clothing line the one where
she's balling from the clothing line and
she's actually she's not doing it next
year
mm-hmm because i think she's doing so
well from the club i think she had
that's going
to hurt her that she has like a game
plan because some people will get on
these reality shows pop
off but they don't know what to do
afterwards like they don't have a route
to go and keep growing after they get
off the show i got another one for you
that was reality star
trey songs nope riff raff river from
he got kicked off the first episode yeah
he made that lasting of an impression he
was
such a fun character i'm like bro y'all
should have kept him on
and the way he gets kicked off is
hilarious he was like oh y'all don't
want me here
y'all want me gone
oh it's like that yeah bro it's the game
dumbass this is the funniest [ __ ] ever
he's like
y'all don't want me here man
hey who's the og of like reality shows
would it be flavor of love because
that's
real because he didn't start his reality
but that's a real yeah but that's called
made him relevant yeah that's
that's what made him really famous yeah
the simple life i remember growing up
that was huge
hilton and uh real riches
i can watch riff raff videos how about
how about he got cast on the show
showed up with the mtv logo on it on his
neck the cat
they were like god damn dog though how
about him on uh uh sway five in the
morning
i'm saying get on those styles yeah he's
just funny he's just a cool girl
he's just a funny guy dude do you
remember when he was uh bulking when he
got on steroids
yeah because he was trying to become a
biggest [ __ ] a wrestler yeah he's trying
to come to like the wwe
shout out to our wrestling fan shout out
to riffraff dawg
let's be friends
he was katy perry's date to the vmas one
year yeah he was
i didn't know that yep he was katy perry
get around
that's him a yellow wolf yeah he's
interested in dude because he stayed
relevant you know i think it was a joke
at first but then his
videos kept popping up on world star
like every two weeks
like god damn he's putting out content
he's like he just has that it factor
yeah yeah funny
look lit too or we can't play it huh
no oh damn i wish man let me let me hear
that chick these songs crack me
up dog bird that's this ground fight
this one yeah uh
he's got better ones though this is the
new one though let me hear it
three million september 26 that's old 10
weeks
bro is that true yeah i mean he just
says [ __ ]
are you a fan of his music i actually
[ __ ] with it do you [ __ ] with it yeah i
like his beats
his videos are funny how does he not
have feel in this music
no much right does he is he signing a
record deal is he's independent he's
i think uh he was co-signed by like
diplo
oh wow diplo [ __ ] with him don't talk
about the record deal
uh i don't know there's something with
diplo like that
man and he's an empire he was an empire
son he signed to dj company
yeah he has to constantly create content
huh yeah because
i mean people take his music as a joke
like he's like an eddie milinakis kind
of guy but
i think i feel though right i think it's
just better it's better but people will
look at them like that you think still
yeah hundred percent yeah i i honestly
do people people
look at people people still live like
they don't make fun of them but they
just
they just look at his like raps as like
jokes
he's a little dicky but he says some of
the flavors he can rap we know
but a little dicky i don't think he can
rap but also he's a little dicky also
wants to be a comedian riff raff doesn't
little dick
is a comet trapped in a rapper's mindset
so yeah he came out and said that he
wanted to rap
and make it funny in order to become a
comedian like he didn't
want to be a rapper he did it with the
intention of being a committee he's
brilliant
the whole premise
his whole concept of this video is how
you should save money he wants to make a
music video by saving money
so they're just in beverly hills he goes
to [ __ ] hundred houses like
hey i need a house for my music video
and finally one lady lets him do it yeah
then he gets a dude's yacht he could
talk to him
this is real then he gets a lamborghini
which that was tp
let him use it for 10 minutes yeah then
t-pain shooting a music video he goes
talk to t-pain he's like hey can i use
your crowd so it looks like it's my
video he's like sure
so he didn't pay for that he gets in the
club with fetty wap it's dope
yeah because yeah they would have been
all the different clubs yo so this is
one of my favorite videos it's a great
video
i'm gonna watch it well i get it i mean
it's great yeah
uh rip with riffraff yeah a lot of
people don't don't take him like
they can say seriously but i mean if you
go to his concerts and you see like you
see his shows and they're literally i
mean they're lit
like people have fun with them so it's
like but he's like
you know like you're not gonna you know
i don't think
j cole fans are gonna go to [ __ ] a
riff raft
unless they've got a wide range in taste
yeah i'm not because j cole fans are
just literally like lyrics
they like nash that kind of stuff yeah
and then oh you know j cole this is like
he don't dis he'll just try to like tell
lil pumps and
all those young rappers who just like
make good beats
and just have like a catchy hook yeah
you're not going to last that long you
also has a legit point yeah but he has a
joke
but also does he have to say it well let
those people
ride where they ride that's what i
always feel about when it comes to stuff
like that like
well you know why is he threatened you
know what i'm saying like is he
threatened by it otherwise
he came out and says that it was more so
like he was giving advice to
rappers he was telling them get your
money but just know you need longevity
oh god i got it yeah he was an industry
and he's right yeah so he wasn't hating
he was just saying like bro
and people the little you know young
guns our generation we quick to
oh so they start snapping and they kind
of like took it as
it's called middle child it's a great
song by the way oh great song yeah
[ __ ] yeah so so that should ask jay your
brother to send it to me
oh yeah jay loves jay loves jayco he
knows his favorite
oh yeah that's his like did you know
jacob's favorite
i know yeah
oh you know what we need to do for uh
palm beach uh we're there december 29th
through january 2nd holla come see your
boys
we need to rent some [ __ ] uh dope
cars
like lambos bro let's let's let's shoot
a music video
i got the little sean disc on the way
one
you're gonna take a hard l what do you
mean i want nothing dude i got a couple
of bo i got four bars it's gonna kill
him you ready
i'm a big sean fan i know but you hear
me yeah
he said i know but you gonna hear the
little shine this
oh yeah i'm trying to tell you it's hard
it's hard to be part of that but the
point is
uh we want to rent some dope rides so
anybody who does those uh
exotic car rentals holla at us you
really want to do that
yes yeah i don't like driving those
shits why you've seen how i drive my car
yeah i see we'll do it down there i
don't know but they're not my wheels you
were swerving
in a goddamn suburban oh there's
somebody i never just took out
some [ __ ] there was no snow it was
going down the hill
it was going down the hill this was just
like yeah we going to the vehicle
like literally he's driving like this
over speeding like he's tokyo drift
yeah i got pretty wild damn calm down
he said [ __ ] that stop sign it's going
out man
there was no boise like everyone had
their
like you go by the house yeah one house
had a light off
like everything oh that's so scary it
was crazy it was crazy brittany didn't
give a [ __ ] what is that
amityville horror [ __ ] is that what
that's like no uh
oh the movie that was a good movie
houses and [ __ ] um it's not a house
where people are killed yeah like a
haunted house yeah
yeah that was based off a true story oh
it is
is it really yeah that house has been
for sale for the family
very similar premise to the shining
where it's like somebody goes crazy in
the family
kills everybody that's a true story or
based off true events no no true story
well it's you know everything's based
off trigger events but in the early
morning hours of november
13 1974 a man named ronald defeo
jr shot and killed his mother father
four siblings while they slept in their
suburban home
uh emilyville knew new york defeat was
convicted for murders and remains
incarcerated today
wow he's still uh oh so the he blamed it
out of the house
he blamed on voices you can buy the
house the house let me see the house
it looks oh you know why they gotta why
they gotta why they gotta put in
black and white they literally have to
do with that you have to
you know what i mean show me good please
sketches scare the [ __ ] out of me
really says they purchased the home for
80 grand it has to be in 1978
74 13 months later there you go so how
much now but now it's for sale again
but like the uh we talked about this the
mansion the house is where the murders
happened were for sale
and there's one los feliz which is super
haunted that just went for sale
yeah wait how much is that amityville
horror house
they said 8 000 right back then oh back
then i don't know how much you said 72
000 back there do you think
so those go up in prices because it's
like this has this thing
i don't know like based off a house like
that some of them are tough to sell like
that one that really hunt it's like the
most haunted house in l.a
los filas it's like they're having
trouble selling it yeah
it's a hard sell but i feel like people
would only want to go and stay for a
couple days like an
[ __ ] airbnb haunted tours every
halloween it's lit as [ __ ]
and people always passing by your house
and [ __ ] yeah my house drives by that
manson house i don't know
what's that yeah scary little doll legs
see they don't have to do these pictures
but they just 850 000 now what the hell
oh that's how much oh [ __ ] he's they
said ultra low play and
oh looks like it's haunted do they have
a gingerbread pictures
of the inside probably who the [ __ ] is
buying that house
no one i would never do that no one no
one even spares no anything like that
do i believe in what like evil spirits
no you don't
you seem like you do i just shook my
head no but
i guess paranormal activity did you
watch it yeah the first one [ __ ] me up
i thought it was really actually after
that the uh the other ones weren't as
good yeah yeah it just got rewarded
for me but that first one dawg i'm older
than you guys but when
the blair witch project came out and it
there
when their marketing came out said this
is real footage yo ghosts and [ __ ]
me and my friends wait in line i forget
at fox theater
in denver colorado shout out there was a
long line we got in there
i was so [ __ ] scared oh i was
because i thought we all thought it was
real yeah everyone was just the
marketing was pretty good
they told the actors that they couldn't
like reach out to people once the movie
premiered
to make it seem like it was they did
really good with nobody could ever do
something like that again no yeah
because now like you know but at the
time it was like everyone's lying like
damn you know this is really like that's
real like
like you thought you were watching so i
went in and you're just like holy [ __ ]
then we got out of there and everyone's
dude i said with the lights on for days
yeah and then like weeks went by and so
i was like you know that shit's fake
right
and then they printed article that's
fake you watch that [ __ ] when you know
it's fake
it's the worst movie ever it's
so terrible yeah i haven't seen it it's
the worst movie ever made
yeah it's only cool if it's if you think
it's real it's so bad
damn it's so [ __ ] bad really you
might watch it is it on like amazon
it probably is it's not on youtube dude
youtube it's kind of wrong it's a
complete waste of your time
they did a modern one too like more
recently last year or two they have a
new blair witch project
oh they made a new one i mean what did
you know that's something yeah
yeah they're like maybe we can get them
again
they [ __ ] got me my friends man we
were [ __ ]
terrified the one that yeah the movie
that [ __ ] me up the most
is 1999 more recent uh was uh the
strangers
that i think strangers is good yeah the
people with the mask yeah
with uh to me that's more scary than
like what's the daughter's name oh liv
tyler live tile yeah yeah
yeah that that's because that [ __ ]
actually really goes down that's the
[ __ ] that scares me
not this [ __ ] like vacancy you ever
seen that hell yeah what the
owen wilson wilson that got there the
hotel in the hotel they like they come
in there
yeah they kill people with the little vc
bro hell yeah
yeah so they're chilling right they're
chilling and uh he's like oh there's a
vcr there he goes there's a [ __ ] vhs
center
and clicks it and it shows of like a
couple in the room getting murdered
and he's watching he's like what the
[ __ ] is this thing he's looking he's
like
he looks at the light he's like this
looks like this light it looks like
that's this [ __ ] room and then they
start [ __ ] with them it's nuts
how old is this bro this [ __ ] came on
2000 and
2007 seven 2007 yeah and that one got
you pretty good
i went to the movie murder and real
stuff i just i don't enjoy that stuff
yeah because that [ __ ] really happens i
just too close to home yeah it's just
i was ever since you saw that weekend
video i saw i was i was 16. how about
that
world star video you saw me watching at
the airport that russian dude slapped i
was just slapping
just slapping it was like some weird
religious thing but it had no kind of
stuff [ __ ] up or something but he was
slapping this woman yeah
so [ __ ] hard he would speak and point
at people and uh
it was like he was doing it but it
wasn't just her i mean they only showed
him slapping her
but like it was like a row of people
i've never seen somebody get slapped so
hard in my life and
i get knocked out like dug the goose but
he was like like she messed up and he's
like proving a point yeah he was like
yeah
and he was like sermon and then like he
was slapping a shot out of her
you say big russian dude and going
yeah yeah and just her i couldn't take
it yeah it was just her
oh they got slap of the week okay does
she make wings don't slap things have
you seen those where they do the slap
contest
oh my strip clubs and stuff yeah it
makes no sense
makes no sense to me i wish i would oh
so i'll sign up but i don't know why
this
reminds me of that but shout out to
charlemagne signed a five-year new deal
we're coming at this club oh breakfast
oh hell oh wow it's that 10-year
anniversary yeah
ten year was on monday monday did you
listen to it it's good they go to their
favorite moments
what was the favorite uh well when
birdman came in
birdbath yeah and there's some respect
i'm talking about charlemagne said uh a
week prior
uh birdman's uh agent was like hey you
get me in studio
next week on wednesday and he's all of
course i am he's like
cool birdman wants to come through and
charlemagne was like ah [ __ ] he was i
knew ahead of time is gonna be issues oh
he did
and then he said he was he was that
never scared me because you know
you know charlemagne's been punched in
the head yeah yeah there's videos of it
he said the person that scared him was
nelly nelly yep he's like nelly did you
listen to it wait what happened
because he's like like nellie's there
like he's not promoting something this
is yours
and then he says something to nellie and
now he goes you say what you want to say
man you keep talking this [ __ ] say what
you goes
i got laura on retaining fees for [ __ ]
like this he's like so if you want to
keep talking like that
and then you see charlemagne like oh i
want no heat man i want no problems
well he's got what loyalty so basically
if i whip your ass this lawyer
already has the feast to cover me so i'm
not going you know and he looked like
and everything he said looked real like
nelly and he went back to the regular
interview you could just see
really charlemagne he's man enough to
admit that he was like i'm not scared of
these rappers because you know they
smoke weed
they drink these but he's like nelly was
yolked nelly was calm
and he was like i keep lawyers on
retainer fees for problems like you yeah
what did he say about nelson i don't
know i can't remember some issue with
him
yeah but the birdman was funny because
uh birdman was
you know talking shooting he goes why
you want to [ __ ] with the radio guy yeah
yeah yeah yeah he said why are you
[ __ ] the radio guy my favorite part
is when birdman goes
is y'all finished are y'all done all
right then we're all finished
the soldier boy interview was good too
oh soldier boy that was the only way it
was great
hey jake he's all dre he fathered yeah
he's just talking about the whole flow
yeah
the whole interview says 13 minutes no
no no no no it's not that one that's
this isn't just talking about that thing
oh yeah well maybe it's in there but
then there's also uh dj
envy with dj drama oh yeah they have
shawn man was like it was some beijing
beige crime
that's [ __ ] hilarious it's a
privileged fight oh
[ __ ] he was like he was weird he's like
just two beige dudes staring at each
other
is this it that's the whole interview
though do you know how yeah i don't know
where the party's at
yeah you but yeah never i i take schultz
i said doug
find out find out how much xiaomi got
paid
because it has to be [ __ ] rocks
oh it has to he's the i mean he's the
face of it oh dude
i'm not tuning in to angela like
she has her own show that does well
though they're good together they're
good together did you ever hear how
webby pronounced uh charlemagne and
angela you need angela lilly
i swear to god he says yo it's like
charlotte it's like an animated version
of him just mispronouncing it
it's so goddamn funny but i would assume
charlemagne they had to pay because they
they
i was reading this article they said
every big like corporation was trying to
get him out of
uh breakfast club oh they wanted oh all
these people wanted but uh charlemagne
made the point he goes
i stayed with i forget what the network
it is but he goes i stayed with them
he goes because they know my value
because they have the actual numbers so
they see
what i bring to the table these other
people who they don't have he's like
they actually know and they paid me for
it
yeah good for him because he started the
the podcast network the all black
podcast network he
uh he just does a bunch of [ __ ] dude he
showed love same thing
definitely yeah he also said the
premiere networks but
i don't know i hearts where they're at
though
oh that's what they're with 10 years and
their first guest was ray jay
that was our first guest first guest
ever ray j
one wish have you guys seen the
interview that ray j does with his uh
glasses he says like they're unbreakable
he backpedaled i think a month ago and
said that uh
on the anniversary of that clip being
like a year old he said that
he did it on purpose he's like it's
marketing it was great marketing
no you're still talking about it right
you got to break your product online if
you're trying to sell it
you remember when uh this man though
charlemagne drake
oh yeah ray j has a bunch of [ __ ] going
on what were you saying charlemagne and
drake you remember they had their beef
they did have a little b and that's why
drake never uh did the breakfast club
i mean he's never done it i mean drake
never does a lot of interviews he does
but elliott wilson yeah well i'm talking
about it because like the stuff like
that bro but
this is pretty does that sit down at his
house but this is like pre-drinking like
before
especially in the hip-hop like breakfast
club by far the biggest show to do yeah
but think about they got
obama on that [ __ ] [ __ ] flex
is pretty good
like they got like people come through
there man bro
nah i don't listen to you bro no okay
club is like a big boy in the
neighborhood in l.a
oh yeah not anymore everywhere everyone
i love big boy but
everyone they come here they go here's
what's interesting about big boy i've
met him
uh i met him once and like five years
went by and had to do something at uh
the sony studios and i i see him and i'm
like
you know what i don't want to like say
what's up because they don't notice you
and he goes
brendan chob good to see him like holy
[ __ ] oh he ruined you know remembers
names
i went damn you reading names like that
he goes never forget a name he's like
[ __ ]
damn i must have met him for like
someone's like hey this friend shot me
oh yeah what's up man and then literally
like just like that
and then four years later that's
happening he's like what's up brent and
john i'm like
holy [ __ ] dude are you good at
remembering people's names like
celebrities
literally terrible literally the worst
i'm good with faces
yes faces you're really good at names
terrible terrible names
i i i can watch a whole season like dude
whatever yellowstone i can't game i only
know rip game of thrones i don't know
anybody's name
i don't know what it is any character on
the fantasy i don't know
i couldn't tell you and you watch it
like couldn't tell you religious i don't
know why it never sticks with me
what about you do you remember people's
names yeah i remember names and i
remember
birthdays oddly enough what that's weird
birthdays
yeah you tell me like one time and i'm
pretty man i'm bad oh it was justin's
birthday yesterday yeah yeah
he died he didn't forgive me his
birthday we all talked about it
no it has to be like i have to be like
justin when's your birthday and he has
to give me the exact date
and then it's locked in my head what are
you gonna do for your birthday man
just chill you know the city like yeah
no it is
christmas time yeah i never do oh yeah
yeah yeah do the same thing i've been
doing for the last twenty oh we have a
show on your
birthday that's a wednesday oh
hell yeah what y'all doing for my
birthday man probably you don't want to
eat anything
you don't drink either you know we'll
figure it out we'll figure it out you do
nothing i mean i like vanilla cake you
just like vanilla cake yeah
clearly oh dude do you like that what
about like mrs fields
hold on what about a chocolate cookie
with icing on it i love that you you
talking you speaking my language because
i
thought i was like you raggedy ass just
eating vanilla cake you don't like
vanilla cake that's boring
chappelle no way tomorrow vanilla cake
thank you are you serious
that's vanilla vanilla cake are you just
like vanilla you know it's like
super vanilla thank you like i like mine
a little mix yummy oh
i see what
i was like
so you just like the old-fashioned like
uh white
uh no i'm saying like the no
i know what you're saying either
chocolate or white inside yeah yeah
you like vanilla frosting i like caramel
i like caramel as well what the
caramel cake is that is what do you what
do you usually do on your birthday
sprinkles
what do you usually do on your birthday
oh gosh i don't think something about
food
is that a strip club i know not just
chill like last year
i my parents uh invited me over and they
like threw something it's just like
nothing i
know it's nothing no birthdays are weird
like he can give all right look on the
23rd of my birthday
i gotta play my uh little sean this one
here live on there
i mean that'd be my gift to you i guess
yeah i don't know the fans i don't have
the rebuttal
the rebuttal man should we add big sean
on instagram too
dude i don't want that he i'm a fan so
you keep
if he sat down right here i'd be like
what's up dawg
you gotta understand though like listen
he name a big
sean song in the last two years that
you're like okay i like that
bring up this catalog
so ztfo detroit ii
lithuania they don't remember these i'm
trying to tell you i don't know
body language asap
body language stop it you that even if
those are real oh what about one man can
change the world
2015. 2015. 2015.
thank you sam you see what i'm saying
y'all like when was your last hit
that's another good point on the 23rd on
the 23rd 23rd
y'all about that i'm about to wake you
all up rolly boy is about to wake y'all
up that's so funny yeah he doesn't have
a ton of
thank you but he has a ton of features
too though exactly yeah he kills it on a
feature yeah
i don't want to be a whole big sean out
i just want a little taste of it
oh do you remember when kendrick lamar
got on his song control
embodied him yes oh yeah you see i'm
saying like he's not listen no
he had beef ever since where's that
kendrick lamar how about oh
i think it's coming i feel like every
time he's quiet for a while
with all the [ __ ]
you know j cole was supposed to drop
last night jake holt it was trending on
twitter
uh it just didn't happen it just didn't
happen they always do this
thank you here's the thing who and what
is the dropper did
something's going to happen at uh
midnight y'all stay ready
why don't you tell us when it drops dude
but it's dope
because everyone runs and stream the
album if i tell you it's about to draw
like you playing like i get around to it
but if it's a surprise droplet oh [ __ ]
let me kill you next morning
you have to make sure you're super
famous it seems like that's the wrong
thing yeah
yeah drake did it with one of his albums
i'm just saying you imagine if i was
like i don't remember that
i was like i might be in palm beach end
of the month might not
that's different though
people are like dude what the [ __ ]
hey y'all might want to be in the park
i might not show up i'm gonna let y'all
figure that out somebody popped out
can you imagine the worst marketing ever
walk ups only what the [ __ ] nah we can't
do that just yeah comics can't do that
no no comics
there's only one i mean chappelle heart
could do that but
should we used to do that yeah he was
just jumping at this dropping
oh no he would do uh like big [ __ ]
theaters and do that
what yeah we'd be like yo chappelle's
here tonight and he would announce that
morning oh yeah yeah he would he would
that's you know do that sell out you
have to be so i mean think about people
find babysitters and [ __ ] last minute
yeah you like this once in a lifetime
he's going to be here music huh they do
that you know his house pissed me off
the nike app to do that
yes the surprise god dropped these kicks
like what the [ __ ] dude
you look at me together thank you thank
you it's like a last
minute figure out i get a text like hey
bro you get i'm like wait no but dude if
jay's like yo two minutes these drop
then i'm [ __ ]
i get the impulse buy i'm like i
is want em people buy stuff like quick
yes and there's a lot of bots that buy
it as well yeah there's drawings now
yeah
wait wait wait so what do you mean bots
it's a computer program that
bids for you yeah so my bid like a
thousand times where
most [ __ ] kids just hit once and you
got to hopefully get the pair of shoes
because you have the emails that's why
no one gets really shoes anymore no like
that's why it should sells out so quick
yes it's a bomber because it's a bot
and then a man's poster every time i see
like got him i get so they post a
picture let you know if you got them or
not and they'll say got them
and then their fans will repost their
people that like got the shoes i haven't
got it got them you know
in a minute you've been striking out
yeah i always got to go
you know to the second market really
yeah
that's yeah shoe game's stressful it's
kind of [ __ ] up that's why i [ __ ]
look
give these what you're doing that's why
suplex no
you said you know hey you said
you put the you put those
the other day by the way you pulled the
bands off like it's a l for the show
let me tell y'all bro you could always
get these all right how's the open the
shelf going
oh [ __ ] man last i panicked uh last
night because
i fell asleep watching fancy island i'm
like hey put these [ __ ] out love
island
love island i always call it fantasy
fantasy island is that scary
that came out oh that's right with uh
your girl maggie yeah not a great movie
bloomhouse yeah bloomhouse not a great
movie but uh so i got lazy because i
usually do all the school [ __ ] and i
just put them in these two like
plants and he came down he's like yeah
there's the house like oh damn they
are around they just decided to be out
like this huh yeah
and it was like not eventful at all
nothing at all he was like all right
i [ __ ] up [ __ ] up i [ __ ] up keep
getting creative man
you'd be surprised you got this i was
tired though you got a big ass
you got a big ass uh castle so figure it
out you know you ever seen a real castle
i haven't been to the uk oh the house is
not a castle oh have you ever seen a
real castle
like the guys see those ones what's
those ones uh where they do the jousting
are you talking you sit there you
talking about these times yeah yeah yeah
we seen the castle ones in salt lake the
mormons that's not a catch mormons have
cast
that's a temple that'll be a church
that's the mormon temple ctr choose the
right
oh that's what they dude medieval times
you've been there oh
no i don't i don't enjoy it anymore when
i was a kid i did but i went
i went like probably five years ago me
my girl went on this double date there
but uh reminds me of that uh horrible
idea by the way yeah that's awful
but it's a cable guy when he goes there
oh yeah
yeah and they're eating the food he goes
hey can i get a fork and knife
she's all dude we don't have forks and
knife hints medieval times he goes but
you have diet coke
he goes i got listen dude i got a lot of
tables man
but you had diet coke dude that movie
was good [ __ ] yeah
great movie i've got some current events
yeah let's take a little break from the
shenanigans with the boys because i'm
here to tell you about
harry's harry's is dropping a new trial
set
of harry's and you can get it by going
to harrys.com
fighter you everything you need for just
three
bucks all right three bucks we're
talking about quality
german engineered blades german
blades son new sharper blades harry's is
delivering their sharpest shave
ever and guess what they're not raising
the prices like other brands they ain't
doing that
quality guaranteed they completely stand
by their blades with the
100 money back guarantee on harrys.com
it's available online or in stores all
right harry's available wherever
you shop harry says great offer for you
guys the t
fat k z listeners new customers can
redeem a harry's trial set
at harry's.com fighter for just three
bucks you get a five
blade razor featuring the new sharper
blades a weighted handle
foaming shave gel with alloy and
a travel cover to protect your blade
when you're on the go all right
just go to harry's dot com slash fighter
to redeem your trial offer today
i know my current events are number one
john you're
this is important did you run through it
with your queen no that did it solo
all right okay so you studied by
yourself this week okay
all right all right listen all right
target margaret uh
keenan right who is she she's a 90 year
old
jewelry shop assistant okay she was the
first person
to take the vaccine shot oh yeah yeah
come on man
dude i bet come on brian pass is she in
new york she's in uk
ah she's in the uk she's in the uk love
island
they're they're starting to uh drop the
vaccine right
yeah they're starting to drop now now
the biggest test that i was watching the
news last night
the biggest problem they have now is
convincing the people to take the
vaccine
people are never satisfied man now and
also they said
she was like wait till the vaccine we
stand back well there's nothing with
them you got to realize
i mean it's fair to not trust certain
[ __ ] don't give me the first batch i'm
not saying i'm not saying like
whatever i'm just saying people have
been lied to in ridiculous ways
yeah from you know i think why yeah i
think the approval and trust in the
government is complete
that's all very low right now yeah it's
very low right now so
also they said latinas uh uh cover 19 is
spiking they said latinas
in that language latino only latinas and
black people yeah what are they nice in
the black so not the men no black blacks
no latinos for black people like their
death rate's way higher than
a lot of people so the black community
yeah covet [ __ ] them up
so that's why oh that was yeah that's
why biden
that's why biden came out was like hey
we need to get these vaccines to the
lower income
black families and mexicans and then you
know they're like well why the [ __ ] do
we need it we have to take it first
brian's like dude i'm just trying to
[ __ ] help if you don't take it don't
take it they're making nurse and people
like my mom works in the hospital so
they're making them take it
and now my mom's like well they're at
the most rest yeah well because
she they were like why would we take it
and we're trying to help the people
first like what if we get sick
and who's going to help us so there's
like it's mandatory for
hospital workers you know they have to
take tb tests like my mom had this oh
yeah do all this but
the first vaccine they have to so you
want your nurse like you want them to
take it first
they take tb tests they take all this
other stuff to be a nurse but you you
know
you know what you know eventually to fly
international you're gonna have to have
some sort of
some for some form of proof that you've
been vaccinated by a copay or you can't
come into that country this is the same
thing
if you go to africa you have to get
these shots you got to get the shots
that's what i'm saying you said what
what do you say about that i go to
africa what do you say about the
motherland not going what do you
have a lot of them
i'm not going through all that to go
there but you'd rather go get a vaccine
shot and go to the uk
yeah that's his motherland though you
guys need to understand that's his
motherland oh i see
like you guys trying to get those
malaria and whatever else shots
hilarious you do have to get malaria out
there
because the mosquitoes yeah mosquitoes
anyways but yeah
like nurses yeah they have to take you
know because they're around it non-stop
yeah i mean it makes sense i mean
but to your point yes the thing with
black people uh i did hear that
and i heard a lot of it had to do with
like uh lack of
the the vitamin d levels yeah extremely
low
in black people because that's being
darker yeah we don't like to go out in
the sun
yeah because we love the sun really
no there was a doctor uh no i don't know
the death rate if covered with black
people was like really high yeah
and a lot of it and what they were
finding out a lot of it was the vitamin
d levels
i'll tell you right now if they tell me
the world
will open up i told you this i will
get that vaccine shot in my [ __ ]
eyeball if i have to yeah
i was waiting for it i could eyeball
that's even more extreme
yes way more i'm trying to one-up you
wear glasses
well i'll take them off you ever have a
shot in your hand
like an iv yeah that's the worst that's
right that's the worst
an iv in the hand that's great brian
come on you know when you go to the
veins get the veins
so um non-hispanic
blacks and hispanics 2.8 times
where according to this graph yeah or
this little now does it say
they have more underlying health
conditions because that could be
read the article
hold on so my stepfather got in that's a
pretty big man he's good yeah my
father-in-law got in he has the worst
lungs of anyone i've ever met
and straight but did you see that they
voted that uh they can't do the
businesses and [ __ ] don't have to shut
down l.a no they overturned it
yeah they overturned it but they said
something along the lines of like
it's still not going to open up right
away because we're still technically in
a lockdown
well we're we're under house constraint
so but they do i've seen so many people
outside
i was awesome people are unless i just
came from here you know why because
people
don't trust [ __ ] nuisance and they're
sick
all my people's from i went to barbara
today and got this [ __ ] man
and i don't know why it was lit but well
yeah we
still walked outside with them yeah lit
it was lit i mean
my girlfriend's like it's a [ __ ] y'all
all right you can make it mad enough
i know my great a lot of my people from
back home like my family and [ __ ]
they'll reach out to me and they go
you're not kiddo up a little uh
they'll reach out to me and be like are
you okay like
like you just you're just sitting at
home i'm like set up some of the video
of us in boise like i'm fine
i'm fine but that's bad that's boys
have capacity anyways
what else you got jen
here we go okay so um
this company goya they're known for like
mexican
things like beans i believe you
supported trump right yeah they came out
and supported trump because trump wanted
to
invite a like latino entrepreneur to the
white house kind of talk about
he wanted to invite the owner right
though yeah how to like kind of better
because he supported trump yeah yeah and
he's trying to say like oh look like i'm
not racist and also like let's find a
way to support
these minority businesses aoc came out
and
basically said that she wasn't going to
be buying their products anymore by
saying
that she's going to be making her own
adobo she doesn't want to buy their
adobo
and in july when she tweeted that out
their sales actually went up
one thousand percent and so goya named
aoc their employee of the month for
boosting sales awesome
bro here's the thing though so so she
was pretty [ __ ] so
so she you know she did go anti-trump
remember over 70 million people voted
for trump
so if you get [ __ ] one percent of
those people to buy your product you're
bawling
yeah damn balling they went up a
thousand percent
thousand percent in their beans and
their adobo which is what she said she
was good it's adobo
adobo is i believe a spice but i don't
know what their version of it for
the canned good is got it
i know chicken adobo yeah they made her
employee of the month
yeah they made her employee of the month
because she helped sales mm-hmm
damn eh shut up she's standing on her
ear she's standing on her own ten toes
what else you got ten toes huh okay so a
twelve year old from
keep happening right this happens almost
like once every four months
a 12 year old child from uh new york i
believe he was from queens
picked up his seven-year-old cousin and
they both drove
in the family range rover from uh
queens to south new jersey they were
right next to the border
damn they got that far split i know
right that tick tock hold on apparently
they were trying to do a challenge where
you get in the car and you drive until
you run out of gas
but they ended up getting on that 124
mile trip that ended at a rest stop in
southern new jersey yep this little dude
drove for 124 miles yep
jesus give me his license now he didn't
even get tired no nope
because i'm usually tired about huh
i was driving at 12 and 13 through now
you was yeah
you used joyriding are you using jj
wherever but the latinos do that bro
i'm not latino you can just tell them
but we take my mom's car
toward the camera you meet my brother is
it on the other side because she's
british who used to drive you or jay
when that happened uh both of us you
would take challenges take turns how far
apart your names are y'all
two years two years honey he was 13.
uh i was probably like 11 he was 13. it
was his idea though
it would be did you ever find out oh and
then then when the game boy color came
out
the purple jay was 16 so i was 14
yeah and the game boy colors came out
and i didn't watch i didn't want to walk
to toys r us to buy it
because it was like four miles away and
jay had a red convertible mustang
that my mom bought him and it was his
[ __ ] baby and he was gone and i stole
his car and drove it to toys r us
and then came back i thought i'd make it
back before he got home
he was so [ __ ] mad really so mad
all you had to do was wait right now oh
yeah this way patience patience is a
virtue he was an [ __ ] he was mean to
me back then so you probably want to
take me so that's why i stole his car
oh that makes sense
i don't know your history yeah was not
the nice jay now he was awesome oh god
yeah yeah drive that [ __ ] he was so mean
go go hang out with that big ass giraffe
[ __ ] [ __ ] never left your kids yeah
that's right
yeah it's just shut down now it's shut
down man is it it's only online i think
i think it's only online too i don't see
any more toys r us stars
they got ps5s in there dog i got my son
that
[ __ ] um monster truck the
uh what's called gravedigger we were
watching cartoons you know how those
[ __ ] cartoons
they play the commercials so your kid's
like oh i want that they played one this
kid driving the
remote controlled gravedigger and it
showed a kid holding it didn't look that
[ __ ] big
i got to pick this thing up this and you
do the target pickup this [ __ ] came out
in this giant [ __ ]
monster truck i remember seeing those
commercials for gravedigger all the time
because
they would come a lot to the brave feet
of your grave
and then it'd just be like yeah he's
like whoa
see if you can pull dad out tim the
gravedigger commercial grab the old
school gravedigger
yeah that's what we grew up on they used
to they got a new one
he was like dad i want them like oh i
wanted that when i was a kid so i was
like you gotta ask santa
of course this little dude [ __ ]
writing his notes puts it in the thing
look at that's the one yeah these are
come on espn man they have races
no the these were for the toys for the
toys
monster full tweak bomb energy
it was always just cool to watch this
damn commercial
what's great toughest competition do
they're talking toughest competition
dude i took my son like two years ago
remember that they offered us to go to
the show and i went
remember monster truck emailed firing
the kid oh [ __ ] yeah a long time yeah
you figured out yeah probably maybe
three years ago yeah young
really wow so um they have a new
gravedigger no it's same one
the exact same one but they have a new
uh the driver control
the remote control got i got it that's a
big rc
is that what he got that's huge that's
huge oh this looks like a real rc
like an adult what's going on youtube
it's maybe not that's it that's that
thing is
huge walmart which is his new he's a
walmart
he's gonna run over his brother this
thing i guarantee you bossing me laying
on the ground he's gonna roll
hard over you you you were a big toy guy
when you were younger huh
uh toy cars that's why i know well now
oh you can
my son and i play a game when i'm
driving i'll go point out a car and i
bet your dad knows it
he'll point at so and i'll just name off
all the cars damn
there's a point to have all the cars and
they'd have the names on them how old do
you know prius
exactly i used to have one oh why you
had to shut them down like that i know
right yeah
he even raised his chin when he's grave
digger
1000 horsepower really the real
gravedigger yeah you can run so he can
run over the ball
yeah they're soft
that's cool this is horrible yeah shout
out to it man oh he's going to love it
he doesn't watch this were you a big toy
guy
yeah you like toys yeah i have speeds
nerf
super stokers nerf guns shout out to
micro machines
i collected pogs yeah i collected all
the cars i
made model cars ships boats
[ __ ] all sorts of dope ass rides well
then playstation came out and then
that's when i just stopped collecting
[ __ ] videos i play station i was like
you're not a video game guy
i am oh you are yeah i love video games
no i don't i don't play him now come 37
but uh
what does that mean how long do you like
you spend
hours playing right yeah well not hours
it's three that's
three hours that's a lot of times three
hours a day time seven that's 20
up 21 hours think of all the cool sheets
you'd be doing no
no it's 24 hours in a day right i could
play hour here hour there hour like yeah
i limit myself to like
but it's three hours a day now here's my
thing mal let's talk about your life
right now okay
you're going and uh three hours a day on
value again yes
i bet if we bring up your phone right
now see how many how long you're on your
phone too
so between the phone and the games oh
well well i'm on my phone present for
two hours of the day i'm no no on the
phone two hours of the day i'm
so you
what [ __ ] prison has a red light did
you see him in a jump shoot with his
hands like this and then
oh yeah yeah yeah and he said you bought
the bottle of beer
at 12 15. then when he taps it he was
like yeah i bought the bottle of beer at
12 15 yeah
that's a great line oh my god to the
listeners please watch minutes to
society
yeah i wonder how many people get that
reference i know yeah i don't know how
you [ __ ] up right you know you're
[ __ ]
you know you're [ __ ] up right now
hopefully they watch it so they know the
reference every time
yeah but your video games and your phone
dog you out yeah you alive
no well on your phone i'm being
productive i'm writing on my notes i'm
writing jokes
again we can see that on your phone we
can look up how much social media you're
on and how much jokes you're on sunday
they let me know all the time yeah and
it's like social media of course is
going to be above but it
right next to it is notes an email yeah
yeah okay you think does it calculate
podcasts on there too because like why i
ride my bike let's say i write for two
hours
listen to pockets does that count
towards i think it calculates every
and that time no i think it's a screen
time you're not looking at your phone
looking it's not there because i have
these things i think we're uh
it's like a percentage of what you're
using like oh yeah
this percentage yeah um this have this
percentage i think that's how much data
you
it takes up though not necessarily the
time oh got it
right
let me just tell you something right
quick that's crazy so
53 mi so it's like 50 what's in the most
of your day right show your categories
guess what the most category on my phone
instagram okay cool what's the second
one
twitter nah it's facebook knows my
messages what's the third one
is youtube the fourth one is my mail
the fifth one is my photos then notes
youtube
that's what i'm trying to figure out why
should you talk about the phone
or if you plug it in if you play music
oh no no it doesn't show up on your
phone it's music yeah answer it
you don't answer in here so you can hear
huh artists your queen
those jeans aren't tight at all
all righty this was sent in from queen
gigi on
twitter this is for you brendan one of
the sisters
um has lost a hundred pounds her name is
amy
and she's the biggest one yeah because
she got a
surgery that i believe it's the what's
the gastric vitamin
surgery she got it yes uh she got that
this even though her doctor didn't
recommend it because they just said it
wasn't a safe procedure
before you go on have you guys seen the
show my thoughts about sister dog
she was so fat she had fat on her
forehead
i see it
she don't have any eyeballs dude and
then she got a man and i [ __ ] i told
my grandma guarantee he's black
because you know she was like the way
she was talking
and then sure enough facetime is this
black dude
and then dude he came over big dude
listen to the nerve of this dude no
scott skinny dude
yeah chubby black chubby chaser comes
over there
they hook up she talks about them having
sex oh god
sure enough next episode he's married
has a girl
that was a side piece what the [ __ ] was
he thinking
are we going to king shame the man how
crazy is that
but so she she's having a baby yeah so
she had
a bariatric surgery against her
surgeon's advice
they wanted her to wait two years until
she was healthy enough
to get it but she ended up getting it
even though he said
that she should wait she lost a hundred
pounds and she got the smaller sister
this is the one with the fat
but she got pregnant within a month
after her surgery do we know what oh but
she she was married chin can you scroll
up real quick let me see that girl eye
come on i know it's the worst eye you've
ever seen
they were such a good personality though
tlc found them from youtube they had a
show on youtube and they're really
funny that's right yep they're funny man
from yeah uh second season they're
coming out with
uh i believe in my 600 pound
sister or whatever it's 1 000 pounds now
dude
my or her losing 100 pounds like you and
i losing 5 pounds
she was like 800 pounds dude like a
hundred
she's lost more than a hundred hey give
her give her at least give her a [ __ ]
wait were they 600 each or was it 600
collectively
collected thousand pound scissors so
that one with the fat forehead
so even about like 3 800 or 700 and the
other one was like 400.
they have to go to a junkyard to get
weight on because no scales six and four
of five and five no it was like seven
three seven four now she has a baby
she's having a baby she's having a baby
and she is worried because she says a
lot can go wrong with this pregnancy
because of
uh her health yeah variety so she's very
worried
do you know in national it should be
born in national media a lot of women
when they have babies
like they die the women who give birth
not a lot
the women that big no no no women in
general yeah
oh yeah like that's a good for you man
not a good percentage
i don't think the percentage is as high
as you think it would be but it is
19. number wise it is quite a bit
doubled well first of all so it'd be one
percent
one percent what so if it's 10 per a
hundred thousand
that'd be one percent one percent
all right cool again this isn't 1915
okay well i'll just try to give the
women 211 deaths per 100 000 life
births that's global brazil
i apologize yeah yeah this movie you
know [ __ ] up
i forgot i couldn't get this guy's uh
username but somebody dm this to me and
wanted us to react to
this man i guess he makes a bunch of
tick tocks where he sings with his
ukulele
and annoys his girlfriend oh he's really
good though he he is very good he's a
good teacher
you see him hit it
yeah i think we can just switch this
girl's pretty hot
and then um japanese maybe what you
think a splash of japanese i'll say
japanese
she looks like yoko ono oh he can sing
because of what i didn't do and not bad
sometimes i regret it
but then i question what's wrong with
your head
cause i'm not gonna eat your ass
i'm not doing that
she's all what them
what's his name yeah where she was uh
running late for work
in front of me she was running late for
work it was really good dude you better
eat that girl
groceries you feel me yeah you talk
about eating ass
yeah so you're gonna zoom you've done it
wait hold on wait we're getting
something that's not your thing i've
never ever
did you read that no did you already
okay i've done it
i remember this guy this one i believe
is the one that got him viral on tick
tock
i thought he got bigger
wow
i think it's just one of those things
like he does it all the time so she's
like used to it
what's his name i'm gonna try to get him
on a chorus for the little shondis
it's like y dot x official or something
like that okay
this is instagram y dot x dot official
i guess that's his user yeah this is
usually do you guys think though
not hating okay jen you think it's fake
you know all those pranks well they
played together
but it's still good it's like what you
grew up it's still good i don't think
it's necessarily a prank
i think it's just him being silly i'm
getting out of here yeah it's just him
getting on her nerves
but the dmhm
do you consider this a prank video this
isn't a prank this isn't like
this it's not like she knew
that's what she knew well i'm sure she's
aware he's setting up the
the [ __ ] speaker yeah she's probably
like this is lame she's probably like
okay whatever
like it's fine and then she realized
she's actually late though okay so
you're saying that late
for work video is fake i'm not gonna be
like what's the thing that you think is
fake about it like
this is a performance oh you think you
think she was like he was like babe act
like you're asleep and i'm gonna sing
yeah but the thing is like these videos
aren't popular i'm not trying to ruin it
for the people that enjoy it reaction
though
the point of the video is the fact that
he can sing yeah and
and just get on here which is cool i
gotta believe he's a great singer but
i don't yeah like i'm sure she was in
like yeah sing a song about eating my
ass
yeah and now like she's really on a
phone call with what
she's got a phone call with someone i
don't think it's actually like her own
no i don't think that's i think it's
just that like he wants to do something
silly he's like oh can you get on a call
yeah working i know they are saying so
they are working together she's always
saying she's aware of the
no it's not fake because he's really
singing because would you then consider
this i don't think she knows the song
because he's gonna sing
i think he's like yeah which is fine i'm
just saying that they're working
together
obviously it's not like it's not like oh
she's like oh my god
he's singing a song right now i'm on
this important phone call now do you
do is there a part of you that wish you
did this with your girl no
because it'd be fake chin don't listen
to them
i'm with you thank you bro you yep yep
you got to explain yourself yeah this is
a symbol i feel like do you wish you did
that with your girl because
you wish you were a singer i don't wish
i was a singer you can't i could [ __ ]
sing
sing some [ __ ] sing some [ __ ] wish i was
saying i swear
you can barely rap first of all yeah
this track is trash you didn't hear it
yet i don't know bro listen
i got money you think i'm a con man only
last time i seen shine was in sean john
man
did you do the freestyle early he did it
early
we we peer pressured earlier you know
you [ __ ] up right
now did you do it
you and your moms
you and your mom papa john's
oh god he was feeling it out and it
didn't go well
i was so mad at how you all reacted i
thought we were family
damn you did it all right
it's tight dude it's tight can somebody
please give this to big sean i just want
to see what his reaction is
bro please dog yo you was the only one
who was with me i got your man you were
writing those alerts for a hot second i
was ready
this whole show all of y'all i was just
thinking you're waiting that's why he
was writing in his notes his freestyle
bar was like we were talking about he
said i can rap i know right all right
cool
yeah you don't think i can
i caught big sean john
sean john
these are the bricks all right all right
let's just speak
to you good keep going yeah all right
this is going to
bring you guys down though from a high
oh hold on oh no i like some dark [ __ ]
sometimes what do you got
uh this girl right here female boxer
oh yeah three tom she actually fought
three times for the world title
uh she apparently allegedly beat her 61
61 year old husband to death now this
picture's a little deceiving because you
think it's the white girl
beating up the other girl it's actually
the other that's her
brazilian born she's brazilian 34 years
old so a very big age gap
and so there was pictures removed from
instagram but then i saw the dude here
so that should be the guy damn she was
she was
bad why she boxing first of all why the
[ __ ] she with him
that's a great question that's what
their friends were saying to but then
when they saw him together they said
that a really good relationship is he a
lord he just made sense
does he have a castle you know that's
the number one thing i'm going to think
right
but i don't know yeah i know what he is
damn she's brazilian she damn and then
it was in sweden so maybe swedish
yeah he she beat him up so bad she
killed him she killed yeah
and then the thing is they believe it's
because
she thought he cheated on her well [ __ ]
almost brazilians are spicy man yeah
and she had a previous boyfriend from
way back that said that she punched him
in the face too
when he was when she got jealous about
him talking to a friend so she was
thinking the same thing with her
possibly yeah
there's not enough info on this right
now but yeah damn she's a baddie
bro i hate wait go ahead picture her at
the desk again her life's
over the other one well you uh it was on
the other page yeah she's super bad
and the disc you didn't never look at
that oh my
dude piece and she beat damn and she
have hands too
i look that's my dream what
i don't know about that dude be one of
those uh uh prison writers
what do you mean where you start a
relationship with a prison does that
work those pen pals
oh yeah they were yeah yeah yeah like
like uh teddy benson had one yeah
charles manson got married from one
teddy bundy had a bunch of hoes
and and like relationship last like like
i i don't know if they if you're on
death row you get conjugal
business yeah but you can't like you
know she's not gonna be on death row
though
she won't be on death row you could hit
her up or she might hit you
joy they're still investigating did he
swing first uh they're not i don't think
he's alive to say
but also you could the the prisoners are
getting on tick-tock and [ __ ] somebody
could dm her
yo so we remember when we said fez is
easier than
the state or something like that bad
disease in uh the state penitentiary
yeah okay
my friend was like that's not true he
was like he was like state defense is
like harder than state
because he was like fess you sneak in
and he is going to have like a little
easier rules but they're more strict
than prison guards i think they're more
strict
the prison is more strict and there's
more of a regiment yeah but in state
you're talking about gangs doug
my dad was in state yeah that's what a
county is like counties that's where the
guy is
that's jail yeah you know you [ __ ] up
right
one's jail once prison yeah and there's
federal and state
okay so his dad was in state with the
gangs our friend stevie was in federal
conference his dad says
state's worse stevie said state's worse
i'ma listen to them
who's your friend
well she loved them to death not gonna
lie that guy didn't look 61.
he looks older right he looked older
yeah let me see him oh wow i was like i
was like i thought you looked younger
because i was like
i don't think you look 61. i don't even
know what to think when i got
61. face wise i know she's a
professional
female boxer i can't believe she beat up
that dude defend yourself bubba that is
true i don't think he could
i don't know yeah he is 61. but you see
he dressed like he's 61 but then he
looks 71. he's
what do you think of henry rollins henry
ron it's okay well he's like brian
maybe we're almost close enough 53 now
yeah
henry rollins is close to 60. that man
don't look like that henry rollins
has lived a crazy life and only drinks
uh
uh
characters do you know that yes
different animals
i have a different gauge for that
because when i think 50 i think of like
the
stories people tell you about hot girls
like j.lo was 50.
i think of stuff like that those are the
outliers though the outliers yeah that's
what i think of
yo factor 50 yes factor 15 what else you
have to do
right now factor 50. uh someone sent
this talking about how to throw that
[ __ ] out
throw it back fun to use though right
yeah go rewrite your diffs
oh can i explain this one yeah okay so
look
you know let me do i need to see the
video before you explain it no
i'm i'm dressing black and white for you
oh interesting
choices you see where i'm going
i know where this is going okay look so
jamal
jamel hill for x espn sports did she get
voted off the island by ireland i mean
north america
no oh she's still here they still like
she's on vice you know carrie champion
okay i love carrie because she's a
lakers fan as well okay
they both came from sportscenter yeah
he's beautiful how long are we to
pretend she's doing better since she
left
neither one okay this is why this this
is so great so they had jake paul on
their show okay interview by the way
that's big for them
because that's kind of everybody's about
the view huge this girl literally asked
this guy three times
did you knock out nate robinson because
you're racist
what girl asked that jamal yeah no she
didn't i don't know how
do you think it's racist she has a job i
don't know how she has a [ __ ] job
that's not real that's that's what i got
she really asked that well let me play
it so you guys can hear exactly what she
says
give me the context because just off
that shut get the [ __ ] out
you'll be pissed off right um they asked
me three times
um i almost started to protest this show
because why i'll tell you why and this
is our question of the week
we saw what happened to nate robinson so
i'm gonna ask jake paul
right here in front of america jake
um consider where we are right now in
our racial conversation in america oh
hell no
do you see no no no racist see that's
what you did to him racist that's what
she asked
what it's always good [ __ ] question
but what did she mean she meant like yo
are you racist that you knocked out
she could be implying i don't know she
says
is it her thoughts no yes where is this
coming from
we all clown maybe more too though well
that's why that's why she got fired from
espn
watch this nah
stop playing with me come on
listen jake it's a sensitive time right
now we just
had to witness a white man just knock a
black man smooth out
no you know you the black band can't
fight dumbass
when she asked him again about that that
moment real quick because uh it looked
like nate was asleep before he ever even
hit the canvas
yeah i mean this is what we train for
you know at the end of the day boxing's
a sport
and uh you know you trained to win and
that's that's what i went in there and
did and i
i uh i worked hard for this and you know
nate nate is the one who called me out
originally so i think he is frozen hey
can you hear me now
yeah i can hear you guys now sorry my
wi-fi is unstable like my relationship
and then the other girl from the
beginning okay first
and foremost was it racist
to knock a black man out that is the
question of that oh stop
asking me that thank you no it's not
racist
it's a shitty question it's a sport why
is it a shitty question
why is it a shitty question because how
do these dumbasses have a show
anything to do with the race what's it
have to do anything with race
what a bunch of idiots this ruins things
like this
yeah ruins the native because yeah
that's racist so
like what it does is it it takes away
from actual racist
acts no everyone so if that that's
racist that nate robson
signed on to do a boxing what part of
that's racist no is it racist
i have no idea well they they both got
fired from espn for this
exact [ __ ] reason well it's just dumb
it's just like hey
you don't have to do that it'll still
this isn't real journaling this isn't
real you just you just just
that's why both of these dumbasses
aren't vice versa well i don't know if
it's for a clown
this will be the most watched clip
because so [ __ ] stupid well listen
let me just tell you what they did they
brought
everyone together because we all agreed
every nationality that they dumb as [ __ ]
so that's why i think they was trying to
end i don't know that was trying to be
the butt of the joke
but literally everyone blind everyone to
comment
they're being playful but they she asked
the question multiple times
they knew that they were gonna get
clicks by asking this question yeah
that's
i don't know if they actually believe
that something like that is racist but i
do think they know
smart too man i like i like carriage i
don't [ __ ] with
either of them i don't [ __ ] with either
well i don't [ __ ] with that question but
i don't [ __ ] with either carrie champion
is a lakers fan i don't give a flying
[ __ ] i don't [ __ ] with either
all right well we go over there and if
i'm looking if i'm a jake paul just hung
up like y'all some [ __ ] idiots
yeah he was getting upset like that's
what racism is like that's a racist
question yeah what a stupid question it
is i'm not about to entertain your
stupid
your stupidity yeah at all though so
sure you know and i'm always that's
frustrating yeah it's just crazy but
shout out to jake paul for having
patience
because he literally handled it pretty
well because he couldn't he wouldn't
quit
that's a stupid question and if he
didn't hung up that'd be like oh he
races you see what i'm saying so he was
in a losing
situation i don't think jake paul gives
a flying [ __ ] what those two think
though i think those two
were going to make up their minds before
he came on you know it doesn't matter
they make more money than him no not
even close he makes more than both those
women
combined in their own vice paul makes
that youtube
13 to 17 money that's a lot
probably six to seven for that fight
against nate robinson yeah
he is rich rich let me see how many
followers he has right now on youtube
he about to get you know i got logan
paul on my show uh friday
yeah food truck oh i'm pulling up
20.3 million subscribers if you do the
math
i did a long time ago but how many
thousands of videos subscribers you get
with this
he's a multi multi multi-millionaire and
that's just just from his youtube yeah
just from his views and then everything
on top of that if he talks about a
product
all that stuff instagram sponsorships
he's 23 years old yeah but i'm killing
it
all right well god
yeah that kind of pissed you off a
little bit when i when i saw it this
morning
i was like man come on i was rooting you
remember that girl in that little uh
tyra banks oh i wrote it for
um this is not a big deal but meek mill
i guess he filmed himself in an
instagram story giving
twenty dollars to these kids like a few
kids and then he said for them to split
it and then i guess
social media was saying like why would
you give them that that's how stupid
social medias
so these kids in atlanta they do it here
in la they run up with candy bars or
water here in l.a especially in the
summer yeah they do it all they sell it
for a dollar he gave him twenty dollars
he paid twenty dollars for one bottle of
water yeah
social media is mad that he didn't give
him more money because he's a
multi-millionaire he but then he gave
him what is that what you want to tell
people
in their [ __ ] channel 200 [ __ ] was
it 2 000
back return on their money in their
investment so they need to take that
money
and buy more water but he always that's
the hustle he said he always gave he
gave these
kids money before and he was like look
they richard
yeah yeah yeah he was like that's how
dumb social media is
they didn't know that this it was a joke
that's social media but on that but what
chapel said is right who what business
is it of yours to judge someone on how
much money they give someone when
they're just giving money to someone too
yeah why judge that
exactly he could have not given him
exactly what he knows these kids though
that's why he was making it's their
[ __ ] everyone likes to have their
opinion on something people try and it's
almost cool in certain respects to
certain people i always want to jump
into other people's [ __ ]
people need to chill like y'all y'all
back to 50 a lot yeah
factor 50. after 15. yeah that's our new
thing now
factor 50. factor
apparently this is going viral just his
practice so i'll just play it's very
short it's like 24 seconds shout out to
my homie isaiah oh [ __ ]
his dad's clearly maneuvered
like he's also what he's seven for some
seven three
isaiah hawkins isaiah train him he's
such a beast i don't want that out of
here
that's crazy he's gonna do all that and
still lose to lebron in the western
conference fight
it looks good though look good in
training camp baby i'm proud of you
seven for two don't forget you got seven
three can you relax
i said no bet no no you shook on it and
then afterwards you said no bet when you
looked up
yeah no that's the bed bro you got three
jesus i'm confident
uh did you know steve jobs daughter is a
model yeah i did
well i didn't i didn't
i didn't but that's her she's 22 years
old she was at stanford
wow so she's she's that smart i think
listen when your dad steve job yeah well
there you go
she's 22. 22. all right this is her
instagram she graduated from stanford
is there one where she's not in the
weird bathtub like that oh there's that
there's simply another weird one in my
opinion come on chase if you're not
watching this
right yeah right in the picture let's
[ __ ] turn our heads again
breaking now i'm going the images are
going to go through instagram
uh now she's pretty yeah she's nice
be weird if your dad steve jobs right
yeah
i'll be laying down her follow-up game
on point
um she looks young a lot of people don't
but i wouldn't think a lot of people are
69 000 yeah a lot of people wouldn't
know about her though
you know a hundred posts she don't post
the light her name is not like
she's probably pretty private when your
dad steve jobs yeah your money hurt her
mama
exactly yeah she chill she doesn't write
about that create the iphone
oh issa right yeah and so many people
know about your life because he had
multiple movies made about him and she's
like the daughter that he abandoned and
like went back to
shitty person shitty dad ashton kutcher
looks just like he was a better steve
jobs than stephen
absolutely what's this
trump dad this is trump's swing golf
swing oh boy
thick yeah he's so thick you gonna be in
the video
i wish we are going to be in palm beach
that's his home
home state oh i thought he's from new
york
pretty legit but he look he owns [ __ ] go
to that swing again he's a trump man
no it's actually legit because i play
top golf he plays a lot
yeah oh yeah 70 something years old
great shot very nice
those boys jerk yeah
holy one good job man
and this is you know how those monoliths
kept popping up everywhere
these particular people four artists and
fabricators
show that they did it the the first one
that mountain ask
atascadero popping up all around random
places right they're popping up
everywhere now but these people are
taking
credit for this one
them replacing it after got knocked down
and there's like another statue like
jesus or something what's the point
though
just aren't fixing me it's just art yeah
and then this is where they're all
popping up
and these people were like a lot of work
these [ __ ]
aliens i'm like i'm sick of these alien
conversations no aliens ain't dropping
off
it's so boring you're not into aliens
i don't know how that's like so
interesting yeah
if you see something that you think is
an actual alien
cool wait like if it actually
[ __ ] happens then say something yeah
not like this is not this like [ __ ]
where it's like oh look at that thing
that was in the sky
you want proof yeah i hate i don't know
i hate the talk of it
oh wow sorry that was aggressive well
you've been looking all right
i haven't been aggressive the whole show
yes i'm sorry that was that itchin
that was good uh uh well this crew will
be
in palm beach uh december 31st through
january 2nd get your tickets now bring
in 2021 with the boys here
and then tomorrow at 8 a.m
tickets for san marcos texas which is
between uh right outside austin right
outside san antonio
oh you refreshed that [ __ ] there it is
we are there
january 29th through the 30th it's two
shows
uh friday two show saturday and that's
at the mark
in san marcos texas we've never been
it's
gonna be [ __ ] lit it is limited
capacity limited seating so tickets can
go fast
they go on sale as you listen to this
thursday morning 8 a.m
uh pacific time san marcos texas get
your tickets
at the mark uh but before that we're in
west palm beach
december 31st through january 2nd
holla all your thick boy gear
thickboy.com we got the new tie-dye
short sleeve hoodies
thick boy uh trucker hats we got it
there man thickboy.com
defectkay.com for tickets is that it
boys yeah now get that love is tight
hoodie it's out now chappelle
right there baby 20 off with promo code
lit lit
i get those uh t-shirts man you know
what i mean i get yeah
all three of those
how are you so funny all three i
understand why
put like this if you get a t-shirt i
give you a snippet of the little shine
this
t-shirt is a freestyle for you
hey he's got a freestyle on his
instagram come on because it is pretty
good you did say you're not mad at don't
wanna we in the studio with you yeah
yeah it is pretty good freestyle yeah
well i got a lot of hoes and i got a lot
of clothes
or something like that don't worry about
i don't know what you say hello i got a
lot of girls
got big sean and sean john wait no no no
look rolly boy
i got a lot of shows and i got a lot of
flow come on
all right man oh god
damn this is so good nice bro are you
serious
[ __ ] insane you'd love to
you're a mile away from the comedy store
so you get delivered oh wow
were they cool mm-hmm is that the only
one they have out here yeah
this is the first location the only one
i believe
i think there might be is there one
there's
and so jay's best friend lives in new
york we're looking for the best pizza
he's like you gotta go to the prince
he's like all the tacos that gets the
spot
this is the best pizza bro this is the
[ __ ] i'm not even bullshitting you
i'm not trying to ride somebody
jock strap i'm drunk seriously mm-hmm
for the ground it's not i might post
this for the grinch
show my appreciation
bruh you got a bee shop special
i don't oh i do now
i see this i will oh
i can taste the positivity so positive
so positive let me get deep in there
get deep in there like you know how
people tell sponsors
usually it's the only square slice of
pizza you'll ever see me eat
mmm
i'm just having one slice are you
serious yeah just one slice
i have one in a bit how long
huh